pendant huit ans Maxime a été démineur
dans l'armée ukrainienne
j'ai obtenu un diagnostic affirmant que
je ne peux plus le faire je peux
seulement enseigner
après son retour d'une mission
particulièrement dangereuse l'été
dernier quelque chose s'est brisé en
Maxime
il y a une forte explosion et à ce
moment-là c'était comme la goutte d'eau
qui fait déborder le vase quand tu te
dis que tu en as marre quoi ils n'ont
pas pu me sortir du sous-sol pendant
deux jours après ça
aujourd'hui dans sa vitrine parmi ces
médailles des médicaments qu'il doit
prendre tous les jours
celle-là c'est pour dormir
c'est là des antidouleurs ça aussi
un syndrome post-traumatique c'est
quelque chose qui s'accumule avec le
temps
à l'hôpital des anciens combattants de
soumis les psychologues gardent cela en
tête ils organisent des ateliers qui ont
pour objectif d'empêcher le stress
post-traumatique de se développer un
SketchUp nous avons encore le temps
d'aider et d'orienter ses passions pour
ne pas qu'il laisse toutes ces émotions
grandir en eux parce que la plupart
d'entre eux ont vraiment vécu des
expériences difficiles très
traumatisantes
ce n'est pas possible de juste de
l'enlever de la tête et d'oublier
ce sera toujours là
tu dois apprendre à le mettre en
arrière-plan
a été hospitalisé fin décembre il était
devenu agressif et s'était tourné vers
l'alcool pour s'endormir je me
réveillais et je crie en pleine nuit je
voyais tout le temps ces blessures
mais moi aussi j'ai tué des gens c'était
à distance rapprochée
Alexander restera ici pour encore une ou
deux semaines mais après cela il affirme
qu'il soit de rejoindre son unité
au Pérou